the other big topic that will be touched
on by the home secretary later on today
is violence against women and i hope you
don't mind that we devote the rest of
our time together to dealing with this
particular topic she's expected to say
that she's redoubling her efforts to
ensure women and girls feel safer do you
accept the fact that in this country we
have a problem with violence against
women
oh yes i think we all accept that and
that's why earlier this summer we
published a violence against women or
girls strategy where we commissioned the
inspector for constabulary to look at
the policing of violence against women
and and girls we had a report on that
earlier this summer obviously over the
last couple of years i've been policing
minister and we've done a lot of work in
this area particularly concentrating for
example on domestic murder and domestic
violence and i've been leading the work
in the government on the regrettably you
know disgracefully low conviction rates
that we have around rape and sexual
assault so there's been a lot of work
that's been ongoing but look we still
have a a problem um in this country
that's been encapsulated in the response
to some of the horrible murders not
least sarah everard and sabine nasa that
we've seen over the last couple of weeks
to which we as a government have to
respond um and the fact that there are
too many women and girls out there who
just feel unsafe in the public realm
does demand that we constantly increase
and reinforce our efforts to make sure
that they and everybody else feels safe
sure but but this has let's let's be
fair about it this has happened on your
watch the conservatives have been in
person since since 2010 so rather than
judging you on the promises that you're
making right now shouldn't we be judging
you on that on that record that you have
just mentioned rape convictions at a low
they have dropped so significantly over
the past five years that when the rape
review came out in june of this year the
victims commissioner vera baird said
this what we are witnessing is the
decriminalisation of rape why should
anyone trust the conservatives to be
able to sort this out
well look we have obviously apologized
uh profoundly for that fall the reasons
behind it are complicated um and to do
with issues of disclosure in court and a
loss of confidence if you like between
the police and the cps about dealing
with those cases what i well what i
think people want to see is that we are
very focused on this issue and we've
pledged to try and drive those numbers
up and as i say i'm leading that uh task
force we've been doing that for the last
few months to try and restore that
institutional confidence if you like and
people coming forward now i would say
that during that same period the
confidence of people to come forward and
report that crime has increased very
significantly so we've seen a big rise
in reporting um over the last four or
five years we have to respond to that
operationally and make sure that more of
those cases to get into court but it's
worth it
but they're just not but again as you
say in the rape review ministers
collectively said they were deeply
ashamed understandable given the fact
since 2016-17 the volume of cases
prosecuted has dropped by 60
the amount of convictions that we're
securing has further dropped women do
not feel safe on the streets uh honestly
right now for the conservatives to
describe themselves as the party of
party of law and order would be somewhat
hubristic wouldn't it
i don't think so i mean i think that's
unfair right i mean we are obviously
trying to propose a strong package of
messages which will give people a sense
of security in the public realm women
and girls obviously primary amongst
those groups the prime minister came
into office whatever two years ago
and having been a crime-fighting mayor
in london with a proud history i have to
say of dealing with violence against
women and girls we published at city all
the first ever strategy to deal with
this issue uh in the country and in a
major capital city around the world this
has been a thread of activity for him
and i have to say that that's great
you had the opportunity to actually do
something about it yep it was in terms
of an opposition day but
you voted against the full rollout of
section 28 which would allow for the
cross-examination of vulnerable
witnesses to be pre-recorded rather than
take place in court you also voted
against making street harassment a
specific crime you had an opportunity to
do something about it admittedly
presented by the labour party but rather
than hold your nose and do it you voted
against it
no that i mean again i think you're
mischaracterizing the nature of those
debates in the in the house and by the
way what happens in the house of commons
very often has little to do with what
actually happens out there on the street
so for example on your section 28 point
we have rolled out section 28 for
vulnerable victims to every single crown
court in the land and we are at the
moment carefully rolling it out in these
cases to a specific number of crown
courts to make sure that it works and it
embeds because of course section 28
while it is obviously of use for victims
who feel vulnerable to give their
testimony early it does present
cross-examination problems later down
the line now we need to make sure that
the interests of justice that we roll
that out in a proportionate and a fair
way rather than just a blanket easy
solution and it's worth remembering you
know that these are very very
complicated and difficult crime some of
the most difficult to investigate and
prosecute and while it's it's easy for
the labour party to to make these big
bold claims you know we need to be
focused on results and that no one is
denying that these crimes are difficult
to prosecute minister no one is denying
that but the reason this is so difficult
to prosecute is because of the cuts that
you have made to the system since 2010
the cps has faced a 25 budget cut 30
reduction in staff police forces in
england and wales have lost 22 000
officers between march 2010 and march
2018. you're building them back up again
but fair enough they're still
historically low the ministry of justice
has seen its budget cut by 25
up until 2019 2020. those are the
actions that you have taken and we are
seeing the outcomes
no i don't think that's fair and i
wouldn't connect the two uh i mean
obviously for the first robert buckland
whatever connection
the previous
like all parts of the public service big
choices were made in the last decade
because of the position that we all
faced economically and that that cuts
were a factor i think is self-evidently
the case robert buckland said that
well i'm afraid i disagree with him and
i can point you to an example right when
when the prime minister and i were at
city hall uh when we arrived in 2008 uh
knife crime was rising very
significantly at the time police officer
numbers in london were an all-time high
and gordon brown was spending money like
water and all the things that you've
talked about now we managed to get those
numbers down against the background of
of cuts that we were making to the
metropolitan police budget because we
had to the country was facing a
financial crisis and over the first five
years of that term or so crime fell now
obviously things have to move and crime
is agile and times change and so we have
to be as well and what we're trying to
do is design a package of criminal
justice policies and capacity and
capability that will deal with the
challenges we face now and they are very
different to the challenges that were
faced 10 years ago some of those like
the issue we've talked about about rape
come about because of developments in
the criminal justice system and
development in society others of them
like the the growth in online fraud are
because of developments in technology
and what i think the british public want
to see is the government which is
committed and agile in that response and
that is what i think you'll see today on
the on the conference floor
knowing least of all me will criticize
this government if they manage to
improve the rape conviction rate but it
does rather feel that it has taken the
rape and murder of a young woman by a
serving police officer to give you all a
kick up the back side to try and do
something about this
well again while this is obviously a
dreadful dreadful event and it has
encapsulated a feeling in the country i
think that's unfair too the rape review
looking at this issue of the fallen rape
convictions was initiated two years ago
um to do a root and branch review of
what was going wrong in the system we're
seeing the fruits of that work now now
the violence of women against girls
strategy was initiated i think 18 months
ago published in july this year again
engaging with the sector to work out
what we need to do so there have been
lots and lots of strands of work around
this but look neil you know the fight
against crime is never ending and i
think what the british people want to
know is that we are dedicated that we
are bothered that we are being
industrious and throwing everything we
can at it and as i say we are designing
a system which can deal with the
challenges of today
rather than argue about the challenges
of a decade ago and i think and hope
that people will start to feel that in
the years to come